the One Piece manga just revealed the
real name of one of the godosei and I
accidentally used it to crack the hidden
logic behind the entire one piece series
not only do we now know that the gurose
are five of the seven most powerful
people in one piece and how they keep
the world in Balance but also what might
have really happened between the gurosei
emo and joy boy and how Luffy and
Blackbeard tie into all of it now the
guru say that gets revealed in chapter
1073 is this guy here with the white
locks and the massive scar across the
left side of his face his real name is
revealed to be Saint J Garcia Saturn a
name that's truly no one expected
because you won't believe how much
information we can pull from just this
name I promise you're going to love this
okay so the first thing that we can
deduce based on the Saint title is that
the gurosei truly are Celestial dragons
themselves this was actually only
revealed quite recently for the longest
time it was believed that the godosei
were actually lower in Authority than
the average Celestial Dragon dragons who
were simply in charge of running the
world while the Nobles themselves could
enjoy their luxurious lives however
during the revery Arc it was revealed
that the godose are nobles themselves
with much much more power than someone
like this guy who Luffy punched in the
slave auction house and now this kurosa
in particular Saturn seems to be from a
family called the J Garcia's which
surprisingly is only the second world
Noble family name that we have heard in
the story next to the Don quixot family
and so from this weekend now deduce that
the Celestial Dragon seemed to have a
somewhat Spanish sounding theme to their
names the donkey kot family and the Jay
Garcia family donkey kot is of course
based on the famous book character
chasing windmills but Jay Garcia doesn't
immediately ring a bell that is unless
you're really into rock music because as
it turns out Jay Garcia was the
guitarist and singer of a rock band
called The Grateful Dead and to be
honest there is quite a lot of
similarity between him and Saturn but he
is not the only inspire operation for
this particular Guru say now in case you
don't know all FIFA de Gordo say are
probably inspired by famous politicians
of the past the Bold one with glasses is
most likely based on the Indian
revolutionary Mahatma Gandhi the guy
with the birthmark and the giant
mustache is based on the last Soviet
president Mikhail Gorbachev this guy
with the ridiculously long beard looks
very similar to the Japanese politician
itagaki taisuke the blonde guy who
basically looks like sanji's long-lost
Uncle is based on a young Abraham
Lincoln and finally Saint J Garcia
Saturn looks like Karl Marx and don't
worry this will all make sense in just a
moment now all of these figures
represent very different political
ideologies and all of them have their
own flaws but what unites all of them at
least from a historical perspective is
that they are all heavily associated
with giving people more freedom Lincoln
was of course known for ending slavery
in the U.S Gandhi ended British colonial
rule in India Marx's fundamental idea
that was then later strongly misused by
multiple regime was the theory of
Liberty stating that the freedom of the
people is the most important right that
should not be exploited and controlled
by those with power and money Gorbachev
was the last president of the Soviet
Union who with his ideas of glasnost and
perestroika openness and restructuring
promoted Democratic thinking and Liberty
in Eastern Europe that ultimately led to
the collapse of the Soviet Union and
finally itagaki was leader of the
freedom and people's rights movement and
involved with the founding of the very
first Democratic political party in
Japan now there's really only a handful
of things that we do know for a fact
about the gorosei surprisingly even
though they are the five most powerful
people in the world only answering to
the secret ruler emu they were only
introduced in chapter 233 of One Piece
the gurusai have full control over the
Marines and all the Cypher poll agencies
in fact Rob Lucci zp0 serves only them
which by the way makes stussy's role as
a double agent even more interesting in
his chapter I really wonder what
infamous Nation she might have overheard
from the five Elders that she could
share with the straw hats we also know
that the gorose are fully aware of the
true history and what has happened
during the white century and there's
even a very popular theory that all five
of them are actually from the void
Century themselves former Kings of the
20 kingdoms that created the world
government who have then been granted
immortality the gurusai have also
conducted a number of great cleansings
over time whenever a new threat to the
world government's rule has popped up
however one thing that we could only
speculate about so far was their actual
physical power as Celestial dragons it
would seem likely that the gurusai have
enjoyed a life of luxury without pain
and suffering like all the other world
Nobles however not only do they not wear
the same goofy looking spacesuits as the
other world Nobles but they also seem to
have real battle experience the bald
gurosei is always wielding a sword that
many believe to be the show daikitetsu
The Supreme grade version of Zorro's
sandakitetsu sword or the nidai kitetsu
that we saw in one the guy who looks
like sanji's Uncle looks extremely fit
as well and Sant Jay Garcia Saturn has a
large scar across his face that really
suggests he has seen some battles as
well so could the guru say themselves be
hiding some truly powerful abilities I
think with the reveal of Saturn's name
there is a really high probability that
the gurusai cannot only fight but that
they are 5 out of the seven most
powerful people in one piece but Manu
how in the world can you say that so
confidently when you just have one mere
name I was getting to that geez so the
first thing you probably noticed about
the name Saturn is that it is a planet
duh now this of course is interesting
because the planets are named after
Roman gods who again are based on Greek
gods and as you already know all three
of the ancient weapons are named after
these Gods as well and thus after a
planet pluton if Pluto Uranus is the
planet Uranus and Poseidon is the Greek
version of Neptune now these are the
last three planets in our solar system
well at least they were when Oda started
writing one piece little Pluto's not
quite survived since then as a planet
and now if you know your planets using
whatever memorization phrase you learned
in school you will know that Saturn is
the next planet in line now coincidence
you could say but first of all those
don't exist especially not in one piece
but check this out there are nine
planets three of them are ancient
weapons one is Earth itself which leaves
us with five remaining planets for five
of the gorosei Saturn Jupiter Mars Venus
and Mercury and suddenly the Japanese
word gurose makes a lot more sense up
until now it used to be translated as
the five eldest Stars however the kanji
4 star here also means planet in other
words the kurosei are actually the five
Elder planets and on top of that by
revealing just one single name Oda seems
to tease all of the gorosei's individual
powers and positions and there are
actually two options for what those
powers are are number one are based on
the Roman gods we know that Poseidon is
the god of the sea and the ancient
weapon Poseidon shirahoshi has the
powers that are connected to the Sea
Luton which is hidden inside the giant
volcano on wano seems to have powers
connected to the underworlds like Pluto
and Uranus is speculated to be connected
to the sky just like the gods of Heaven
now going with that logic saying Saturn
could have the powers of the God Saturn
god of time Jupiter who is Zeus in Greek
is the God of Thunder Mars is the God of
War Venus is the god of love and Mercury
or Hermes in Greek is the messenger gods
and God of trickery and to be honest all
of these would be plausible powers for
each of the gorose however I would argue
that these Gods aren't actually related
to their powers at all I mean the God of
Thunder to me sounds a lot more like Eno
the God of War doesn't really really
make any sense power related love to me
is just Boa Hancock and being a
messenger sounds like a pretty lame
power to me so instead I'd like to argue
that these are not the gorosei's powers
but rather their role as heads of the
governments Mercury would be in charge
of communication and messaging be it
with the Marine Cipher Pole or people
like Shanks Mars would be the go to say
in charge of War he would be the gurusai
who was organizing the war at marineford
for example Jupiter I personally think
would be the guru say in charge of using
the ancient weapon Uranus after all it
looks like the world government used it
to destroy an entire Island just a few
chapters ago and Saturn I'll go to say
in this chapter would be in charge of
anything related to time and history so
it would only make sense that he is the
guy who's coming for vegapunk who has
all the Lost Knowledge from the ancient
Kingdom that was gathered by the
researchers on O'Hara as for Venus and
love I have really no idea what that
would be a about honestly that's a bit
of a hole in that entire Theory maybe
Oda took her as the god of prosperity
and not love and it's the god of saying
charge of finances or something like
that let me know if you have an idea now
if the gods connected to the planets
aren't the true power of the guru say
what is well let me Flex my uh Japanese
skills a little bit for this because
there are specific kanji for each
planet
Title by the way Uranus has the kanji
for the sky and Neptune has the kanji
for the ocean and these three are kind
of in their own category the five
planets connected to the five Elders on
the other hand share a completely
different category of symbols they are
the five traditional Chinese elements of
Ki fire Woods water Earth and metal Mars
has the kanji for fire mercury has the
kanji for water Jupiter is wood Venus is
metal Kinsey and Saturn is Earth Dulce
and honestly I think that these five
elements make way more sense for the
gorose's true power than the Greek gods
I mean firewood water Earth and metal
could be versions of devil fruits or
some other sort of special ability
comparable to the ancient weapons but if
you think we're done here we're just
getting started because the best part is
what comes next because these five
traditional Chinese elements aren't
alone the entire ancient system is
actually known as the doctrine of Yin
Yang and the five
the words the five elements surround the
yin and yang dark and the light that
bring balance to the universe so next to
the five Guru say we have a force of
light and a force of dark that keep the
balance in the world I wonder have we
ever heard anything related to light and
dark in one piece in the unlikely case
you still haven't caught on let me show
you this this is one normal week in the
Japanese calendar and you'll notice that
5 out of the seven days of the week have
the exact same kanji as the five planets
slash the five elements Tuesday is fire
Mars Wednesday is water Mercury Thursday
is wood Jupiter Friday is metal Venus
and Saturday is Earth Saturn the two
remaining days are you guessed it Sunday
and Monday the day of the sun and the
day of the Moon same in Japanese Sunday
has the kanji for the Sun and Monday has
the kanji for the moon yin and yang
Darkness and Light the fight five
elements also I'm really grateful to Oda
because thanks to one piece I now
finally understand the logic behind both
the weekdays and the planets in Japanese
thanks so the sum part of this diagram
is now pretty easy to fill I think
that's of course the sun Gods Mika this
is how the gorosei are directly
connected to both Joy boy and Luffy now
the Moon part on the other hand could be
two people I think either it is
Blackbeard the kid who never sleeps the
dark opposite to Luffy and the kid that
was crying under a moon or it is emu the
secret ruler of the world the person who
defeated joyboy and the ancient Kingdom
the darkness that balances Luffy's
lights and really when you think about
it it makes sense on so many levels why
Luffy's devil fruit is so important what
it means for Luffy to have become Joy
boy why Shanks who cares about the
balance of the world was meeting with
the gurosei and white Blackbeard is the
polar opposite to Luffy and if that
wasn't enough yet this system might
actually tell us a little bit about what
happened during the void Century for
instance it could mean that the gurosei
once all ruled over different planets or
it could mean that the guru say emu and
joy boy were once allies that created a
balance across the world until emu
decided to betray joyboy to break that
balance another alternative could be
that it will take both Luffy and
Blackbeard the reincarnations of Joy boy
and Roxy's back together in order to
bring balance back to the world and take
down emu who broke that balance in the
first place and if you think about it
that might also explain why the godosei
are modeled after politicians who are
known for bringing people freedom
because maybe they are actually a force
for the goods the five Gods waiting for
the Sun and the Moon Gods to return to
bring back balance to the universe as a
complete set of seven which would of
course also explain why Shanks would
work with them as well now I was
puzzling most of this together while I
was writing a script like like five
minutes ago so if you want a follow-up
video on this where I have more time to
think about it and puzzle more things
together let me know by subscribing to
the channel and in the meantime here's
the review of last week's chapter make
sure to check that out as well thank you
so much for watching